le rapprochement entre washington et la
havane est ce que ça pourrait avoir des
répercussions sur le tourisme
les canadiens vous savez
particulièrement les québécois sont très
nombreux chaque hiver allait profiter
des plages profiter du soleil à cuba
leur mort de bayonne a évidemment kipré
qui craint une répercussion sur les prix
parce qu'on croit on anticipe un
éventuel engouement des américains
également pour les plages de cuba et la
preuve julie que les canadiens aiment
adore même tout bas c'est leur troisième
destination favorite après les états
unis et le mexique
mais attention oui les prix pourraient
augmenter d'ici un à trois ans suivant
le principe de l'offre et de la demande
mais les experts pensent qu'à moyen
terme les prix pourraient se régulariser
voici là dessus
françois de grandpré ils seront vite
compris b quoi c'est le soleil on va les
chercher le soleil les plages
by youtube on mai paul et c'est pas la
seule place moins que la dé consommer ce
produit le balnéaire
il ya la floride il ya la californie il
ya tous ceux qui se retrouvent dans les
caraïbes sont capables de nous offrir ce
plaisir là
donc s'il ya des changements dans un ça
veut dire que les gens voyageront peu
plus ou moins c'est qu'ils vont aller
ailleurs
et puis l'offre touristique à cuba aussi
pour être amené à changer le oui parce
que peut-être que des investisseurs
américains seront intéressés à investir
installé des chaînes hôtelières à cuba
ce ça fait craint une certains cubains
notamment eduardo pena chang qui lui est
à trois rivières depuis 13 ans qui tient
aux paysages à l'âme de cuba et il a
certaines peurs à ce niveau c'est qui me
dérange un peu c'est la l'authenticité
de la culture qui viennent ce qui ça
pourrait si c'est comme les côtés
positifs du gouvernement castriste c'est
qu'ils ont essayé de garder la culture
cubaine au tenté comme et les six ans
arguments ceux des pays totalement ci
commence s'ils commencent à pousser les
mcdonald's partout la csu se serait pas
aussi authentique c'est ça qui ménage un
peu ce serait ça va se faire
éventuellement et sur les trois millions
de touristes qui visitent chaque année
cuba 38% sont et canadien merci beaucoup
monde je vous en prie au revoir en
soirée